on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the right-hander kevin gausman gosman
29 years of age he's in his seventh year
at the big league level
two down and christian walker will come
up
and this one gets away and bart can't
find it and now it's too late so here's
cole calhoun
got him
his walker is picked off and that's
gonna end the inning it's just underway
on this labor day zach gallon when his
last four starts has given up a total of
three runs including two starts against
these very same giants all right here's
dickerson hitting 269 of the years
shattered the bat bounced up the middle
ahmed for one and they get two
well that bad is firewood right now nick
ahmed turns a double play two outs two
down now for donovan solano
swing and a miss gallon has his first
strikeout wyatt
matheson's major league debut right here
man
in the dirt and matheson with a swing
and a miss
second strikeout two down nobody on here
is david peralta left-handed hitter
they've got the over shift on for him
got him and that'll win the inning three
up three down strong inning there
forgotten crawford the shortstop gallon
is back even in the count two and two
and sure enough he gets the strikeout
three outs on 10 pitches for gallon both
gallon and gausman showing signs that
they're not going to allow too many hits
tonight 7th place center nick ahmed
leads off against kevin gausman
got him struck him out on another
splitter that is the fourth strikeout
already for guzman among the first seven
hitters
fastball is knocked into right field
varshall will stop at second
base hit for carson kelly first
diamondbacks hits it out against kevin
gosman josh rojos now the lead off man
at second base tonight
he did not go doug eddings and gausman
has walked two in the inning
they are loaded with one down for katel
martin
bounced up the middle crawford's there
for one and that's it var shows home and
the diamondbacks take a one-nothing lead
here's walker who
struck out and reached on a wild pitch
three pitches
now six total
joey bart to catch here
bart down swinging the fastball elevated
up around the eyes and he swung through
a third strikeout for gallon and two up
two down here in the third inning here's
mauricio
fastball is there and he rings up
duvonne
four strikeouts for gallon he's retired
eight straight and leads it one nothing
the i chance for wyatt matheson who
struck out in his first career at bat in
the second inning two-two pitch is swung
on and missed strike three splitter
grossman gets the strikeout his sixth of
the game so far up comes david peralta
runner at second now one out
got him
change up has just been the money pitch
he has not thrown a slider he has not
thrown a curveball it has been all
fastball and chain challenges yeah set
down eight straight yastremski who has
the giants only hit the leadoff man the
o2 and a swing and a miss strikeout
number five for gallon one out here in
this fourth inning
fouled off of dickerson's foot
hit him in the knee i could gotta be
coming out to see where it got him and
get him some time
there's a spot
he's not moving around very much
no he's trying to shake it off and it's
not happening and alex dickerson's
coming out
so they'll attend to alex dickerson and
darren ruff will step in the big right
hand banner
last ball is there
and gallon gets strikeout number six
rojas who walked in the third inning
he got him strikeout number eight
on to the sixth inning christian walker
powerful right-handed hitter leads off
for the d-backs two-two pitch swing of
the miss he struck him out with a high
fastball base is loaded and nobody out
the ostrinski has singled and then
gallon struck him out
on the ground in a base hit
it's gonna score one
and bart is gonna put on the brakes at
third and this game is tied so here's
ruff
ruff shoots it up the middle for a base
hit
this is gonna score a pair
is
coming home from second is dubon and the
giants lead three to one so here is
solano the pitch
swing line drive base hit left field one
hop to the left fielder varshall who
comes up throwing to the cutoff man
matheson so another line drive a hit
there's the walk and that plate's
another run
and it's four to one well that run is
significant because it ends the streak
of consecutive starts for zach gallon
since he began his career at 23
consecutive games of allowing three or
less runs what a great run for that kid
here's a 2-2 and floors on the ground
down to third matheson goes to the plate
out over the first out double play
that's big
that goes 5-2-3 on a nice play by wyatt
matheson
huge play for the d-backs two outs for
crawford the ninth man to pass swings
and lifts it
in the air to left
on comes bar show he's there he's got it
and that'll finally on the inning back
in the bay area diamondbacks down three
as we start the ninth inning our final
game against the giants this year david
peralta leads it off against sam cunra
2020 rules peralta hits one high and
gone into right field david peralta
his third of the year don't go anywhere
it's four to two
another line drive home run by a
diamondbacks hitter very similar to the
one that dalton varshall hit completely
out of the stadium into mccovey cove
david peralta a little more toward right
center but
a screaming line drive over the fence
112 miles an hour off the band of david
peralta
[Applause]
tap to third robertson charging gets a
weird hop stays with it ball game
[Music]
so the giants end up
winning three straight after that very
troubling loss
on friday night
and they're back to 500.